[Music]
after nearly two weeks of competition
for more than four thousand of the
world's top disabled athletes the
paralympic games come to a close
tomorrow this morning lucy craft
introduces us to one of one u.s athlete
who's a star both inside and far beyond
the sports stadium
in her paralympic debut blind swimmer
anastasia pogonis got right down to
business grabbing team usa's first gold
medal with a world record time in the
400 meter freestyle an assistant gave
her the news with a tap on the head when
i came into the wall i got one tap for
gold two taps for silver and three taps
for bronze and i got that one tap and i
will never forget that moment
so you knew before anybody had said
anything to you that you had won the
race
yeah because they're not allowed to talk
to me on the playing field um
so i got that one tap and i knew that i
had one gold
the 17 year old later won bronze in the
200 meter individual medley hagonis
competes in the s11 class the most
severely visually impaired
an autoimmune disease left her without
sight and despondent just three years
ago my parents would drive me out of the
house just to take me for a five minute
walk while i was literally kicking and
screaming and throwing a tantrum for
going on a five minute walk
but now she's a champion swimmer and a
tick-tock star with two million
followers mixing goofy humor with brutal
honesty pagonus demystifies life as a
fun-loving fashion-forward teen who just
happens to be blind they assume that i
have to wear blacked-out sunglasses and
have my cane and be going around like
this when no i can wear makeup i can be
an elite athlete i can do all these
things and just showing people that they
need to not have that stereotype
she aims to be back in the water at the
next paralympics in 2024.
cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo
that is the olympic spirit no doubt